loved-up in Laguna Justin's cut holding
hands with this new blonde named Sophia
if you don't recognize her you might
know her legendary dad and her reality
TV sister hello
yup this is Lionel Richie's youngest
daughter from his second marriage which
also makes her Nicole Richie's
half-sister the up-and-comers been
linked to the likes of Bella Hadid and
she's even done some modeling herself
after Sofia spotted getting handsy with
Biebs and admiring a seal the paparazzi
later catch her leaving his mansion the
morning after in her pajamas considering
Justin's been hanging out with handful
of models lately it's hard to tell if
Sofia is something serious or they're
just friends
but if she is Bieber's new fling there
might be one tiny problem her age
Sophia's after all 17 years old what do
you mean rumors of a new romance come
after nude pics of the singer were
leaked online last week and they once
again prompted his dad Jeremy to react
on social media and now it's Drake's dad
taking over the spotlight and their wee
magic extend after Arkells recently told
us about meeting and working with Dennis
Graham we call him Dennis now yeah yeah
everyone else calls me Drake though he's
a friend now it seems now the six year
old has gotten a taste of Fame and he
wants more it's kind of crazy that's a
song recorded by Dennis for an upcoming
R&B album he's even working with
producer Jamie Iovine who has previously
worked for Drake his debut album is
expected to draw up later this month